[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
contact with Visigoths relay was lost
last night all signals flatline to 2600
hours I responded with trooper fire
teams which have since been declared
m.i.a and now you're sending us the
Office of Naval Intelligence believes
deployment of a Spartan team is a gross
misallocation of valuable resources I
disagree commander so that's on you
number six okay you read his file only
the parts that weren't covered in black
ink anyone claimed responsibility sir
only thinks it might be the local
insurrection
five months ago they pulled a similar
job on harmony hit a relay to take out
our eyes and ears then stole two
freighters from drydock that cannot
happen here we just do damn important
I want that relay back online noble one
sir consider it done then I'll see you
on the other side
Howland out Lieutenant Commander sir
I'm Carter noble team's leader that's
Kai at noble two meal and George four
and five you're riding with me noble six
not gonna lie to you lieutenant you're
stepping into some shoes the rest of the
squad we're glad to leave unfilled me
I'm just happy to have noble back up to
full strength
just one thing I've seen your file even
the parts the oniy sensors didn't want
me to I'm glad to have your skillset but
we're a team that lone wolf stuff stays
behind clear got it sir
welcome to reach
[Music]
listen up noble team we're looking at a
Down relay outpost 50 clicks from visit
grab we're gonna introduce ourselves to
whoever took it out and then cats gonna
get it back on line
why would rebels want to cut off from
the rest of the colonies you got a
chance maybe we can ask him George
commander we just love that thing of HQ
back up channels
nada can't say what jamming us you heard
her dead zone confirmed command will not
be keeping us company this trip
shoot-down attempts of lightning so keep
your distance yes sir let's stay focused
watch yourself
there's the communications outpost maybe
a distress beacon
one is down on the bluff
do not want your eyes on the sky so
let's go six all right noble team spread
out watch the approach
before it's clear from this distress
beacons coming through just south of
your eyes peeled
[Music]
make out any id- but it's military why
are we not seeing explosives residue
Nobel three can you confirm any e^x
residue in the area all right looks like
there's nothing here let's move on
your bus circle Weston check it out
noble team you have permission to engage
but be selective we don't need to
Telegraph for presents
[Music]
six into the house go and quiet right
behind you
or knees now they're not rebel they're
farmers look at them as mid crestock eat
but the market Oakman Holly hiding sir
take Nevada Assam seed of Asia Georgia
she kotesashi booze will attract last
night screens company Nichols that
stopped around sunrise he says something
in the field killed his son
get back inside
Holly Gary
noble team double-time
[Music]
anything
new boss I see movement outside your
structure noble to move up to the west
we're about to be flanked damn covenant
contact contact there we go
banshees Charlie one
as clear
Sandow noble standout
contacts damn covenant cheer up his old
virologist turned into a free-fire zone
I need you at that relay outpost now I'm
showing my activity to the east
copy that Jun we're on it six we've got
point
Brenneman
commander seem more hostile activity to
the Northeast
Camille you're with cat6 and I will run
interference on the ground we'll meet
you at the output level three requesting
airlift over
get to work Noble
contacts
no believe I'm seeing heat cigs in
destruction ahead
[Music]
looks like we're cleared lieutenant
boss I'm showing what activity to the
east
advise you check it out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we need to find those troopers now
drop ships evac transport keep the
distance six hold position
six old position clear and LZ
be advised we got hostile dropshipping
bow
stay sharp
[Music]
a zoo
[Music]
we're clear
transport LZ is clear moving for evac
Islamic a transport inbound
noble - sitrep
word route to your location
contacts
searching the compost droppeth in the
courtyard
Elsie's a little hotter down piling six
breaks Oh
friendly
hopefully I've got about halfway through
doing
contact
[Music]
[Music]
just
we need to find the control room put
there can get the relay back online
Emil post here if we flush any hostels
they're yours
alright let's do this
can't see a thing noble six turn on your
night vision
number six search that one
where's the rest of your unit we got
split I don't think they it sounded bad
on the cops all right corporal stay put
we'll get you a combat surgeon damn cool
as my damage found something
now take that six not your domain I've
got a live one over here it's still I'll
release you it Vanek
[Music]
bad guy coming out
that kangaroo pet l- floors stay on the
entrance to handle her five and six
clear the hole
[Music]
non-supe say - i work
there's more wash them out
uncle you come
maybe five reporting targets neutralized
that needs you to reset a junction do it
get back
[Music]
how long question of my life if the
question is when will the station be
back online two weeks earliest this is
plasma damage or major uplink components
of fried two minutes is too long which
is why I'm splicing into the main
Overland bundle to get you direct line
to Colin in Holland you're in my light
commander find out what she knows
what's your name do you live around here
[Music]
our Ned and George shara shara
say buckled over men your accent
sounds familiar shopping John Gotti
friend of yours father shine alone I'm
sorry why would you be
big man forgets what he is sometimes she
just lost her father she needs a full
psychiatric workup she's not the only
one
lock it down both of you get her on her
feet the body stays here thank you sir
signal it's patchy but it's there I'll
take it let's not touch anything you
wouldn't want to ground this place
you
[Music]